so you all know of course about america
first and the u.s is the best and we're
the best country and we're the best at
everything and we have the best people
and we have the best everything and yet
um already canada has surpassed the
united states
in terms of the portion of uh adults
who have received a second or final dose
um yeah as i tweeted when this happened
quote you can buy i don't know if i need
to quote myself
as a david pakman from the weekend you
can buy
all the vaccines you want early but if
you're overrun with anti-vax
americans eventually canada catches up
and if you look at the vaccination
curves for each country
there's really a treasure trove of
information just in looking at the
shapes of these curves which we're going
to put up on the screen
for our video audience if you look at
the u.s vaccination curve
you see that it it picks up in mid-march
when we had
a lot of vaccines already and the trend
is that as more and more vaccines have
become available into may june july
where you can just walk in anywhere no
appointment get vaccinated
the rate of vaccination in the u.s has
slowed down
in the united states because we so
quickly
started hitting anti-vax resistance from
people who don't want the vaccine even
though vaccine supply continues to go up
the curve flattens and flattens to where
we are now
doing only about 500 000 vaccine doses
per day so the
u.s story as seen graphically here
is tons of vaccines rapidly waning
interest now in canada the curve started
almost flat why
well because the u.s had all the
vaccines and
as vaccine supply increased in canada
the vaccination curve went almost
vertical
and importantly it is sustaining in this
way
in the u.s by the time we got to
35 40 doses of
people vaccinated the curve was
flattening canada has surpassed us and
is approaching 50
and it is sustained as an almost
vertical
curve in a month canada is in all
likelihood
going to be dramatically more vaccinated
than the united states
so this anti-vac stuff is lethal if you
are a trumpist who falsely believes
trump made the vaccine if you believe
that
why would you let canada take all of the
vaccine protection from us this is
i mean this is such a dumb way to see it
but as i
as i tweeted yesterday maybe we need to
start marketing the vaccine to trumpists
as a soda
like the way sodas are marketed to
people and call it trump juice
is that what it will take but if you are
a trumpist
wouldn't you want to honor your fearless
leader who made the vaccine
by getting the vaccine that he made for
you
instead of letting socialist communist
marxist canadians use it
remember this is all crazy i'm just
thinking how do we get trumpists to want
it and the gap is
is wild canada is currently vaccinating
about 1.2 percent of its population
daily
1.2 percent the u.s is fully vaccinating
0.2 percent of our population
daily and it's not because we have a
larger share vaccinated
canada has surpassed us now so this will
soon end up being
another complete humiliation
of the united states of america thanks
to right wingers
who are proud about not getting
vaccinated now
it's fine to say canada simply has fewer
people
that's why we're talking about
vaccination per
capita it is absolutely shameful
that the united states with all the
vaccines we have
is struggling this badly to find people
who want to get vaccinated while the
world is mostly desperate for vaccines
and actually getting vaccinated as they
get vaccines
available these spikes we're seeing in
the united states
the masks already going back on in
certain places
expect more of it as people continue to
refuse to get vaccinated now i want to
remind you
the good news continues to be for now
the vaccines provide very good
protection
against even the delta variant if you're
vaccinated and get sick
you're very unlikely to be seriously ill
very unlikely to be hospitalized there's
places where for example at a certain
point last week
every hospitalized coveted patient in
los angeles california county
was not vaccinated that's fantastic but
there will be breakthrough cases
and remember the slower we vaccinate
the more those unvaccinated people can
be vectors
for the development of variants for
which the vaccines are not well
suited so this is a very real issue
we're seeing it in the numbers we're
seeing it in the numbers of what's
happening in other countries
we're seeing it in the numbers of the
spikes that are taking place
some states florida for example just
exploding with cases and the
hospitalizations are starting to
increase
in mostly unvaccinated people if there's
any good news and it's never great for
me that people are getting sick and
dying but if there's any good news
it's that the decision to get yourself
vaccinated
remains a very good decision it's not a
hundred percent foolproof decision but
it is
very very good one of our sponsors is
steady md
primary care the easier and more
affordable way to do primary care and
they're giving you
fifty percent off because you are in my
audience
you just answer a few questions steadymd
will match you with a licensed
primary care physician that's tailored
to your needs
you'll have a one hour virtual
appointment and start
a meaningful relationship with your new
doctor
and from then on your doctor will be
available to you by text phone and video
chat
it's not some random doctor on call
your steady md doctor has a limited
number of patients you get the attention
you deserve and they can help you
with anything your primary care doc
normally
would it's very cool how it works you
don't need insurance
it's just 99 bucks a month no other fees
or co-pays for visits
take the free quiz and see which doctor
is a perfect fit for you
you'll get 50 off your first month when
you go to steadymd.com
pacman no risk no long-term commitment
the link is right underneath the video